hey guys so my wife is
um she's so cute she's asking me to just
say something quick before I film
because we only show you guys photos
every now and then so I'm setting up
everything here I'm going to do a batch
um filming and as you can see it's
extremely hot I'm sitting here with
shorts on very comfy shorts and um I
need your prayers because when I do
these videos I don't just want to speak
what I want to speak Daniel I need God
to work through me me so that's why we
ask you guys to help me and there's a
lot of noise sometimes out here um and
sometimes you know the devil just does
not want me to share the gospel in Truth
and Love and so I need you guys to pray
all the prayer warriors please pray for
me for the next half hour as I'll move
forward to share the gospel in truth and
in love thank you guys for the support I
love you and remember God loves you too
bye